hello and welcome to this video new
Mariano's from spain is the opponent
following the current fashion from the
candidates but d4 is a sideline not such
a bad one interesting actually santiago
beltron radar is the name of the sky you
know maybe i should have taken it's
always an interesting question do you
want to take on c3 early on or not maybe
I should have done that ok I think I
actually remember I study at this like
billion years ago c5 and d5 i think is
blacks reply and now some t5 is possible
d5 bishop f6 Queen takes pawn takes t5m
it's that full compensation maybe
maybe it is i can also go G 590 forward
I don't like those kind of loose
positions okay so i'm shooting for this
and trying to get compensation after
Bishop f6 Queen texty texty five that
really looks like the only okay I
thought it looks like the only
continuation that yeah my promise white
anything but you just take 75 and here I
don't see any problems and maybe no he
doesn't have 95 because of Ruby eight
that's important yeah I'm here black is
completely fine with the payoff bishops
okay so he probably what does he want to
do night you for maybe I'm okay doing
this right if I wanted to go be six I
hope that is really feasible and my
bishop is not getting trapped might
happen I once night h5 here huh
interesting
yeah I will probably have to give this
up don't I mean I don't think it's that
terrible but quite surprising but this
was necessary
check after Knight takes e4 was my idea
Bishop takes root key to check but it's
not that great
and maybe still what I have to do just
shoot for our activity he's not taking
it it's surprising check
hmm Joe didn't quite get why it wasn't
taking the pawn or did I will look
something there possible ok so here I
can just grab for work T 2 it's got
rooked you wonder I wonder ever have
something something better they don't
see it and then down time and so what
why do you allow that very surprising ok
I'm going to play okay Jack I wanted to
do this anyway but with a check it gets
it gets unless that's a lot stronger I
think the position was already losing
provide or close to it I was quite
surprising lots of most surprised me a
lot yeah here there's also g5 but ok I
think this is not bad and this is a very
debatable move but the only critical
test can be Bishop takes Queen takes see
takes d5 yeah I think I wanted to play
Bishop f5 and rook the aid for
compensation not sure engine gives write
a small edge therapies possible very
possible but this is the critical test
after this I'm just okay I can also go
g5 but this is chang i think the easiest
just go for this ending where black
should be completely ok
I probably should have been played Oh
hear differently here that night coming
to g3 to h5 ourselves very annoying the
computer just wants to sorry once to
capture and play this for a quality yeah
that's that's probably okay thanks pawn
structure is a bit worse but why does
some not active at all in this position
cannot attack this pawn so probably
equal yeah this is he could have played
94 immediately this sir was even more of
a problem but the way it was already was
quite annoying yeah I didn't I did not
see this for a long time Jan ok now I
went c4 and he just has to take it I
mean quite clearly and there is no
drawback I mean my idea was to give the
chick and take this but after takes
takes rook cease my desk lady bear I
mean winning probably yes it takes you
for this is a check very mysterious
decision and now black is better here
was surprised that he did not go Rupe t1
I thought would kill one was almost
mandatory ok the engine gives this also
winning but ok this this looks very nice
King his own that takes takes d5 and now
I'm threatening this anyway until here
jack yeah walked right right into this
side into this check ok close game and
I'm nearing 2400 again ok thanks for
watching